you are at Harvard you're one of the
most respected people in the history of
Harvard
um that said you did write a book with
the n-word in it and you also have a lot
of opinions that challenge uh the
mainstream perspectives on race from all
sides well hopefully we'll get to talk
about some of them
but what's your view on Harvard and
universities in general and speech yeah
did you feel pressure from any direction
on
um on first of all the title of this
book the content of the book and in
general your views on Race yeah
I am very laudatory of Harvard
University
um I've been at Harvard since uh 1984.
I
think it is a wonderful place to work
um there has not there I I have
uh you know in in the various positions
I've taken with is in particularly with
respect to this book or all my other
books what is Harvard University done
Harvard University has done nothing but
Provide support sustenance encouragement
um you know I think that uh people get
down on Harvard University I would say
to anybody imagine the following imagine
that the ethos of Harvard University
became the governing ethos of the United
States overnight
tomorrow we would wake up in a much
better United States of America
I um you know I I have
um I've been supported by Harvard
University I think well of Harvard
University that's not to say that I
don't have criticisms of it
but
um
by and large Harvard University more
than by and large overwhelmingly it has
provided me and I think it
overwhelmingly provides my colleagues
with a work setting in which they can do
their work uh without fear
and you know that's a good thing are
there certain are there certain you know
aspects of Harvard University about
which I'm critical yeah sure uh by the
way I think a few people rightfully
wrongfully would um
disagree with you that if the ethos Ohio
University took over the country it'd be
a better place but there's a lot of
interesting ways to break that down
because Harvard is not one of these
though there's a lot of things going on
that are very interesting yes uh but one
of the things that's happening is uh the
disproportionate and kind of aggressive
growth of the administration versus uh
faculty students I I think the power
universities should always be with the
faculty and the students that's where
the beauty is that's where the
flourishing happens and the more you
have kind of rules and bureaucracy and
all this kind of stuff the less powerful
the university is I think that uh at my
University and at many universities
that's right there's too much
bureaucracy too much regulation
uh and you know are there are there
dangers
to freedom of expression
at my University and at other
universities answer yeah there are
there are so uh and this has really hit
home for me there was a there was a
period of time in which I was I was
getting off of you know I I had gotten
I'd gotten off of all boards I was just
doing my work forget it I'm just gonna
do my work I'm not going to be on you
know associated with any organizations
in the last five years that has changed
quite dramatically I have I have gotten
on various I've associ I've reassociated
myself with various organizations mainly
organizations involving academic freedom
because
of what's going on uh at you know on
University campuses again I have been at
least thus far
thus far
uh this hasn't pinched me where I live
but
um you mean in the space of ideas in the
space of ideas and the space of speech
in the face of you know teaching you
know I I haven't I haven't been pinched
but I am concerned about things so for
instance let's imagine that you're
applying for a job you know you want to
be an assistant professor
or let's suppose that you're seeking a
promotion
uh in on many University campuses you
are asked to give a Dei statement
in which you say
um I plan to you know you know one one
of the reasons why you should hire me or
one of the reasons why you should
promote me is because I'm going to you
know Advance the you know the Dei
uh Ambitions diversity equity and
inclusion for people don't know this is
the general the set of programs uh that
most universities now have yes
that's right so you know you've got to
sort of
you know basically
what you're being asked to do
whether they say it explicitly or not
they don't say this explicitly but this
is what they're being this is what is up
what you're being asked to do is to say
I'm down with
the diversity equity and inclusion
ethos program policy campaign
and here's what I've done that shows
that I'm down with this program
and therefore I'm okay
well you know a lot of what I do would
fit very comfortably within that but
let's suppose that I didn't just suppose
I didn't like this
and by the way there's certain aspects
of the Dei you know industry that I
don't like
you mean to tell me that uh you know I'm
being judged at an academic institution
let's suppose I want to be a chemist
let's suppose I want to be a physicist
let's suppose I want to be I don't care
uh you know a you know a Critic of
literature
uh I oppose this program I don't you
know I'm I I don't think this is the way
in which higher education should be
going
should I have to on pain of
relinquishing my ability to be hired
should I have to sign on to this uh just
suppose and let's change it around let's
not make it a Dei campaign let's make it
a makeup America great again campaign
what would we think then
let's suppose it was something that said
instead of it saying Dei let's make it
let's make it say
um the advancement of American
capitalism as we know it
we want you to be down with that what
have you done that shows us that you
believe in the advancement of capitalism
in America
would I be happy about no I would say
this is no
well no with respect to these as far as
I'm concerned
with the you know the Dei statements oh
here's another one
um I just learned and in fact I mean
there's certain things that are
happening
and I must say I mean I'm in Academia
but uh it's it's news to me I didn't
know until relatively recently about
positionality statements
so these are statements in which
somebody writes an article let's suppose
you know I write an article
and
um
it's not enough for me just to submit my
article to some law review or to some
you know some other sort of Journal
now in addition to me submitting My
article
I've got to give a positionality
statement in which I say whether I am
you know gay or straight or whatever
what have you in which I say my race in
which I say my nationality in which I
say my you know my stance toward this
ideological position or that ideological
position
interesting what
is this uh uh becoming a
kind of a standard I don't know how
widespread it is I know there was a very
good article in the New York Times
uh a couple of days ago about these
position alley statements and in fact
that's what sort of tipped me off
somebody had told me there's a law
review at my home institution and I had
a friend
who sort of mentioned this offhandedly
and who said well I submitted an article
to this journal
and I was a little bit taken aback in so
far as
they did have me fill out a
questionnaire
in which in which
I was required
to State my race State this state that
state the other
and
you know
um
as far as I'm concerned well
what does that have to do
with
a proper assessment
of somebody's work
This concerns me
um I'm concerned about the fact you you
know a little while ago you mentioned
a little while ago you mentioned the
word negro
uh and I was talking with colleagues a
couple months ago and somebody mentioned
that
uh this word had come up in their class
because what happened was
one student was
reading from a Supreme Court decision
and the word negro was part of what they
read out and another student held up his
hand
and said to the student who was reading
a you should be careful
because you know I find the word negro
offensive
and you need to be careful about even
saying a word
that would be offensive to someone and
this person and then you know the
teacher was you know well you know you
know what should I say in those
circumstances you know what should I
have said
and I volunteered you know and you know
and you know and I said well gosh that's
really interesting because see if that
had come up in my class
um I would have said well frankly I
don't you know I don't see what the the
I don't even see what the big deal is
because I use the word negro
and
um
you know Harvard University is not on
you know on some Island that is
you know apart from everything else
that's happening in the world if these
things are happening in other places if
they're happening at Stanford if they're
happening at Yale if they're happening
at Columbia
uh you know they're gonna happen at
Harvard
um but thus far and I'm I'm I am most
especially
experienced in life at Harvard Law
School
Harvard Law School
Is An Open environment in which ideas
are tested
and they are tested fully
and uh it's it's it's because of that
that I say I have been fully supported
at Harvard Law School feel that it is an
excellent place in which to do work I'm
I'm a fan I am a fan and I'm not
embarrassed to say it I am a fan
of uh of of my workplace Harvard Law
School I'm very happy to be associated
with Harvard Law School zooming out uh
in general in education there's
something called critical race Theory
um can you comment on what are your
thoughts about uh
this kind of perspective on race and
race in America to the degree that it's
becoming a part of the education program
okay so the first thing I want to say
what is it well the first thing I want
to say about critical race theory is
that critical race theory has
become a term so I'm going to put
quotation marks around the term critical
race Theory
we can we I'm in a minute I'll talk
about critical race Theory without
quotation marks but to begin with I want
to talk about critical race Theory
because the reason why people are
talking about critical race Theory so
much now is because politicians
mainly Republican
right-wing politicians
have
created a boogeyman
critical race Theory with quotation
marks around it they have created a
boogeyman
and they have tried to make it seem as
though this Boogeyman
believes all sorts of ideas that
Americans should loathe
and that Americans should fear
and they've created this Boogeyman and
they've created it and they've done a
very good job of creating the Boogeyman
and they have mobilized uh sufficient uh
um you know public support such that you
know there are a number of states that
have passed laws
uh prohibiting
the teaching of so-called critical race
Theory now the first thing I want to say
about this is that
um this campaign this these laws these
various policies telling teachers don't
teach this and don't teach that and you
can't you can't use this book you can't
use that book
this is a frightening encroachment
on freedom
freedom of speech freedom to learn
freedom to listen freedom to read
that's terrible and it's one of the most
frightening things that has happened in
American Life in recent memory so that's
the first thing I want to say about
so-called critical race Theory now now
I'll say something I'm going to take the
quotation marks off of the term critical
race Theory
critical race theory is as a sort of a
you could have a nice conversation about
actually what it is
um one way of viewing it is to say that
well critical race theory is a community
of ideas
that comes from a community of people
the community of people would be people
in legal Academia
in the
um
you know the period 198 starting and
probably the middle of the 1980s
it would be associated with people like
Derek Bell it would be associated with
people like Kimberly Crenshaw people
like Charles Lawrence people like
Richard Delgado people like Mary matsuda
and these are folks who held
uh embraced a couple of you know they
they articulated a couple of
propositions one of their propositions
was that
um
liberal
race policy
was insufficient
they would say that
um the racial policies of
person like my old boss Thurgood
Marshall they'll live you know the
Liberal Liberal racial policies were
insufficient
to Grapple fully with the pervasiveness
and the depth and intensity of American
racism their their basic claim and I
think by the way it was a good claim
their basic claim was that American
racism is more Central
more deeply embedded in American Life
than uh most people perceived including
liberals and I think there was a lot of
strength to that proposition
um
but then they also took on some other
propositions with which I was in very
strong disagreement
so I think it's perfectly fine to say
that racism is a force in American Life
that is deeper more pervasive more
stubborn more resilient than I think
people often you know often understand
often perceive
but then some of the folks you know in
critical race Theory
um push further
uh one of the propositions that some of
the people in critical race Theory took
was the proposition that um
uh America was doomed
to always be a country
that would be governed
according to the dictates of white
supremacy
uh Derek Bell who was a colleague of
mine and a friend of mine took that
position he talked about the permanence
of uh racism in American life and he
took the position that the various
changes that had been wrought in
American Life
were really you know mainly cosmetic
uh they didn't amount to a whole lot I
mean Derek Bell took the position you
know the second reconstruction the Civil
Rights Movement
well it made changes but at the end of
the day black people were still you know
after the second reconstruction were
still in a position of
almost you know you know I don't know
some of them would even say Neo slavery
well I think that's ridiculous
uh the second reconstruction changed a
lot and as for Neo slavery neo-slavery
were you talking about uh a black
American was President of the United
States between the years 2008 and 2016.
I mean what what are we talking about
here uh there's been a tremendous change
and I think people ought to understand
that now
am I saying that everything is peachy
keen and all right no
uh the United States is still
uh to a very large extent still a
pigmentocracy but that doesn't mean that
a lot hasn't changed a lot has
so I disagree with certain tenets of
critical race Theory and have been very
outspoken in my disagreement if there's
another one by the way I need to mention
because we've talked so much in our
discussion about freedom of speech
freedom to teach freedom of listening
another big problem that I've had with
some of the people who
talk of themselves as critical race
Theory people
has to do with their attitude towards
freedom freedom of speech
some critical race Theory people
think that
uh the American legal system is wrong
in the latitude
that it gives to what they call hate
speech or the latitude that it gives to
what they would view as racist beliefs
uh some of some of the people who
associate themselves with critical race
Theory think that racist beliefs
ought to be expunged
with the aid of state power if need be
well I'm against that
and
um you know I think we were at a moment
a an ironic moment
in which
actually it's the right wing that has
embraced some of the ideas that were
championed by some of this some of the
people who call themselves critical race
theorists you know they say oh we ought
to expunge
hate speech
well the right wing is saying this
critical race Theory that's hate speech
so let's expunge it
and
um so I you know again I've been very
outspoken in my criticism
of uh some of the illiberal
dimensions
of critical race Theory so I've you know
I've been a Critic of
certain features of critical race Theory
I have uh applauded certain features of
critical race Theory
um you know critical race Theory you
know there's some aspects of it that I
think have been useful there's some
aspects of it that I think have been you
know profoundly wrong-headed
um
so that's where I am and I certainly in
you know above all
I certainly am against any efforts to
remove it
from you know the intellectual Universe
it is a part of our intellectual
Universe people ought to know about it
and people ought to debate it and people
ought to be free to make up their minds
to conclude what they will about the
stress and weaknesses of critical race
Theory